>> DHS IS NO LONGER IGNORING THE
LAW.
WE ARE ENFORCING THE LAWS AS
THEY EXIST ON THE BOOKS.
AS LONG AS ILLEGAL ENTRY REMAINS
A CRIMINAL OFFENSE, DHS WILL NOT
LOOK THE OTHER WAY.
DHS WILL FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE
LAWS ENACTED BY CONGRESS AS WE
ARE SWORN TO DO.
AS I SAID EARLIER TODAY, SURELY
IT IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
UNRAVELING OF DEMOCRACY WHEN THE
BODY WHO MAKES THE LAWS, INSTEAD
OF CHANGING THEM, TELLS THE
ENFORCEMENT BODY NOT TO ENFORCE
THE LAW.
I ASKED CONGRESS TO ASK THIS
WEEK SO WE CAN SECURE OUR
BORDERS AND UPHOLD OUR
HUMANITARIAN IDEAS.
THESE TWO MISSIONS SHOULD NOT BE
PITTED AGAINST EACH OTHER.
IF WE CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES, WE
CAN ACCOMPLISH BOTH.
>> Bret: THE PICTURES ARE
HORRIBLE.
THE EMOTIONS ARE HIGH.
THE CRITICISM IS ALL OVER THE
PLACE, AND THE BLAME GAME HAS
BEGUN IN EARNEST.
>> WE CAN DO THIS VERY QUICKLY
IF THE DEMOCRATS COME TO THE
TABLE.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO DO IT.
WE WANT TO DO IT MORE THAN THEY
DO.
>> THEY WILL TRY TO MAKE US
CHOOSE BETWEEN THESE CHILDREN
AND DREAMERS.
>> OUR DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS, EVERY
TIME THEY HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO
VOTE FOR A SOLUTION, THEY HAVE
VOTED AGAINST IT.
SO I HOPE THEY CHANGE THEIR
APPROACH.
>> PUT IT ON THE FLOOR AND LET
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE VOTE.
AND YET THEY SLUMBER STILL.
>> Bret: WITH THAT, LET'S
BRING IN THE PANEL.
FORMER CA ANALYST BUCK SEXTON.
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT AT NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST."
SEEMS LIKE THIS IS COMING TO A
HEAD.
>> IT'S BEEN CONFUSING BECAUSE
THIS WAS A POLICY THAT WAS MEANT
AS A DETERRENT AND DESCRIBED AS
A DETERRENT BY JEFF SESSIONS AND
OTHERS.
DON'T BRING YOUR KIDS HERE
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO GET
SEPARATED FROM THEM IF YOU CROSS
ILLEGALLY.
BUT IT TURNS OUT I THINK
BEING TOUGH ON IMMIGRATION.
TODAY HE SAYS WE DON'T WANT OUR
COUNTRY TO TURN INTO A MIGRANT
CAMP OR A HOLDING PEN FOR
REFUGEES.
BUT HE DOESN'T WANT TO TAKE HER
SPOTS ABILITY FOR THE UNPOPULAR
PART OF THE POLICY WHICH IS THE
SEPARATION OF KIDS FROM THEIR
MOTHERS.
SO HE IS BLAMING THE DEMOCRATS.
>> IT'S BEEN TALKED OF A
DETERRENT IN PARTS BECAUSE OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
IN PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS COME
ON PEOPLE CROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY AND CLAIMED AFTER THEY
WERE CAUGHT THEY WERE
ASYLUM-SEEKERS, THEY WOULD BE
LET GO AND ASKED TO REPORT BACK
AT A LATER DATE.
PEOPLE FIGURED OUT IT WAS A GOOD
WAY TO GET INTO THE COUNTRY.
HE WOULD BE ABLE TO PASS THROUGH
IF YOU BROUGHT CHILDREN.
IT INCREASED THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN USED AS YOU WERE
CROSSING THE BORDER.
HE STARTED TO SEE THE NUMBER OF
CASES PEOPLE CROSSING THIS WAY
SKYROCKET.
THEY NEED TO MAKE A DETERRENT.
PEOPLE FIGURED OUT IT'S A GOOD
WAY TO CROSS.
THERE IS A MORAL COST CANNOT
FOLLOWING THE NATION'S LAWS AND
A MORAL COST TO SEPARATING
CHILDREN FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THEY COME
TOGETHER TO RESPECT THE LAWS OF
THE LAND AND KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
>> Bret: SECRETARY NIELSEN ON
THOSE FRAUDULENT CLAIMS GOING
OUT.
>> IN THE LAST FIVE MONTHS, WE
HAVE A THREE-HEADED 14% INCREASE
IN ADULTS AND CHILDREN ARRIVING
AT THE BORDER FRAUDULENTLY
CLAIMING TO BE A FAMILY UNIT.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY OF CONCERN.
SEPARATION CAN OCCUR WHEN THE
PARENT IS CHARGED WITH HUMAN
SMUGGLING.
UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES, WE
WOULD DETAIN THE PARENT IN AN
APPROPRIATE SECURED DETENTION
FACILITY SEPARATE FROM THE
CHILD.
>> Bret: BOX, NO MATTER HOW
YOU EXCITING, THEY SAY THEY'RE
GOING TO SEEK ASYLUM,
THEY CHOOSE TO SEPARATE, WITH
THEIR PERCENTAGES THREE AND A 1%
THEIR PERCENTAGES THREE AND A 1,
THE IMAGES AND THE EMOTION
AROUND THE ISSUE ARE A POLITICAL
DYNAMITE.
>> TRUMP UNDERSTANDS THIS HAS TO
BE HANDLED.
YOU CAN'T HAVE MOTHERS BEING
SEPARATED FROM INCREDIBLY YOUNG
CHILDREN.
I THINK THERE WILL BE A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO SOLVE THAT PART.
THERE'S A LEGACY OF LAWLESSNESS
HERE AND I THINK IT BECOMES TOO
APPARENT THAT NOT JUST THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION BUT THE CURRENT
DEMOCRAT PARTY WOULD PREFER A
SITUATION WHERE ESSENTIALLY
ANYBODY WHO CAN GET IN THE
COUNTRY CAN STAY.
AT SOME POINT, THEY HAVE TO BE
WILLING TO ANSWER THE QUESTION
WHICH ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE NO
LONGER ALLOWED TO STAY IN THE
COUNTRY?
THEY CREATED THIS LOOPHOLE, A
MASSIVE FRONT DOOR ENTRYWAY BY
BRINGING A CHILD WITH YOU, THAN
IT BECAME EASY TO STAY IN THE
COUNTRY.
YOU WANT TO FIX THE ISSUE OF
SEPARATING PARENTS AND CHILDREN
WHILE BEING PROCESSED.
BUT YOU ALSO DO HAVE TO ENFORCE
THE LAW BY PEOPLE COMING HERE
ILLEGALLY.
IN MANY CASES, CLAIMING ASYLUM
IN BAD FAITH.
THEY ARE SAYING WITH A BUNDLED
ESSAY.
THE WORD IS OUT.
SECRETARY NIELSEN HAS BEEN
ADDRESSING THAT.
YOUNG PEOPLE UNACCOMPANIED, THEY
ARE IN JEOPARDY.
MANY THOUSANDS OF ON THE COMPANY
OF MINORS ARE SO SHORT OF THE
BORDER WITH ANYBODY.
THAT IS DANGEROUS FOR THEM TOO.
THE INCENTIVE PUT IN PLACE BY
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HAS TO
STOP.
IT HAS TO END.
>> Bret: PROSPECTS OF FORCING
A BIPARTISAN SOLUTION, DOES IT
CHANGE?
LAST WEEK THE PROSPECT OF
IMMIGRATION LAW GETTING INTO
LAW, BILL GETTING INTO LAW, WAS
PRETTY SMALL.
>> IT LOOKED BAD.
THEY HAVE BEEN SO MANY ATTEMPTS
OVER THE PAST YEAR.
ONE WAS THE DEAL, WE WILL GIVE
YOU FULL FUNDING FOR THE WALL IF
YOU LEGALIZE THE DREAMERS.
NOW IT IS SOMETHING AKIN TO THAT
BUT ALSO WE WANT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT SEPARATING KIDS FROM THEIR
FAMILIES.
DONALD TRUMP IS ASKED FOR A 44%
DECREASE IN LEGAL IMMIGRATION
WHICH THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BALKED
AT.
I THINK IF YOU'VE GOT IT DOWN TO
A PRETTY SKINNY BILL, WALL,
DREAMERS, KIDS AND FAMILY
POLICIES, MAYBE YOU COULD GET
SOMETHING BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S WHERE CONGRESS IS
HEADING.
>> Bret: THE DREADED "SKINNY
BILL."
>> SENATOR TED CRUZ INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD DEAL WITH
THIS.
THE BIG ISSUE IS THAT YOU CAN'T
DETAIN CHILDREN FOR MORE THAN 20
DAYS.
IT TAKES LONG TO DEAL WITH
ADJUDICATING THE ILLEGAL BORDER
CROSSINGS THAT THEN CLAIM ASYLUM
THEN ENDS UP IN FAMILY
SEPARATION.
HIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT YOU
ADJUDICATE THIS WITHIN TWO WEEKS
AND IF YOU FAIL TO PASS TEST,
YOU'RE DEPORTED AS OF FAMILY AND
OTHERWISE YOU CAN BE REUNITED AT
THAT POINT.
>> Bret: WE SHOULD SAY
SECRETARY NIELSEN MADE A POINT
TO SAVE YOU GO TO A PORT OF
ENTRY, THEN YOU CAN CLAIM ASYLUM
AND STAY TOGETHER AS A FAMILY IF
THERE'S ROOM.
>> AND IF THEY THINK YOU ARE A
REAL FAMILY.
>> Bret: HERE IS A BLAST FROM
THE PAST, IF YOU WILL.
HILLARY CLINTON ON THIS ISSUE.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S ATTEMPT TODAY
TO STOKE FEAR OF IMMIGRANTS NOT
ONLY AN HOUR COUNTRY BUT AROUND
THE WORLD BY CLAIMING THAT
MIGRANTS IN GERMANY ARE CAUSING
CRIME.
IN FACT, CRIME IN GERMANY IS AT
ITS LOWEST LEVEL SINCE 1992.
NOR ARE THESE POLICIES ROOTED IN
RELIGION.
IN FACT, THOSE WHO SELECTIVELY
USE THE BIBLE TO JUSTIFY THIS
CRUELTY ARE IGNORING A CENTRAL
TENET OF CHRISTIANITY.
>> Bret: IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
ON THIS ISSUE, AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE, TOUCHING ALL ELEMENTS.
>> VERY DISHONEST IN TERMS OF
WHAT MRS. CLINTON IS PRESENTING
AS WHAT IS HAPPENING IN GERMANY.
SINCE 1982, WHAT HAS HAPPENED
DOESN'T MATTER.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED SINCE THE
MASSIVE MIGRANT WAVE AND IT'S
CLEAR YOU HAD A 10% INCREASE IN
VIOLENT CRIME, HOMICIDE, RAPE,
THE CRIMES PEOPLE CARE ABOUT AND
NOTICE.
ONE SLOW START TO HIT THE
AIRWAVES.
THERE IS A HESITATION IN THE
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES TO SPEAK
OPENLY ABOUT THESE CRIMES.
WE SEE IT IN SWEDEN AND GERMANY.
THE PRESS DOESN'T WANT TO DEAL
WITH IT.
SHE'S WRONG ON THE FACTS.
RATHER, SHE IS MISCONSTRUING THE
REALITY OF WHAT'S HAPPENING,
PICKING WHAT HAPPENED SINCE
1992.
THEY DO HAVE SERIOUS PROBLEMS IN
GERMANY WITH THE MIGRANT WAVE.
SERIOUS PROBLEMS IN OTHER PARTS
OF EUROPE AS WELL.
MRS. CLINTON KNOWS THAT BUT
RIGHT NOW IT'S BETTER TO PLAY TO
THE EMOTIONS.
>> Bret: WHEN YOU HAVE
HILLARY CLINTON AND LAURA BUSH
ON THE SAME ISSUE, DOES IT
CREATE A BIGGER FORCE?
>> LAURA BUSH WAS AN EXTRA
ORDINARY ENTRY INTO THE DEBATE.
SHE DOESN'T EVER COMMENT ON
THINGS LIKE THIS, AND SHE DID.
THE OTHER ASPECT OF THE TWEET,
HE WENT AFTER ANGELA MERKEL.
SUGGESTING THAT HER HOLD ON
POWER WAS TEETERING ON THE BRINK
BECAUSE OF THIS.
IT WAS LIKE HE WAS ISSUING HIS
AMBASSADOR TO GERMANY,
ENCOURAGING CONSERVATIVE PARTIES
TO TAKE OVER.
THE KIND OF MEDDLING I DON'T
THINK YOU WOULD LIKE IF A
FOREIGN LEADER DID.
>> ANGELA MERKEL IS HAVING
POLITICAL TROUBLE.